[Musique]
recevoir en fait une vraie son
restaurant de falafels renault roule
pour eva depuis un an il est membre de
la coopérative et en est donc un peu
propriétaire
je ne vois vraiment comme une partie de
la coop ça c'est sûr eva a vu le jour en
2019 d'abord pour transporter des
personnes mais les deux fondateurs se
sont tournés vers la livraison de repas
pour aider les restaurants locaux avec
des plateaux comme biarritz le client
lui y voit des frais de livraison des
quatre dollars ce qui est totalement
faux
les frais de livraison qui essaient
plateforme reprenne son de 30 $ sur 100
dollars des baisses ciblées ont été
mises en place mais la coopérative
procède différemment
eva ne prend pas un pourcentage dessus à
part pour les frais de fonctionnement
vraiment mais ne cherche pas à faire du
bénéfice sur les livraisons
dans cette épicerie qui fait aussi des
repas à emporter
passé par le géant américain était
incontournable au début de la pandémie
mais c'est devenu contradictoires dans
une idée des commerces à cala quartier
puis fait la belle part aux produits
locaux train d'étudier hubbard its après
ça pour faire livrer les nourrissons il
fait donc partie des quelques 300
restaurants de montréal qui font
désormais appel à eva et à son tarif
fixe de livraison de huit dollars
renault attend son tour avec ses
concurrents pour récupérer la commande
sur le trottoir et il ne recevra pas de
nouvelle demande avant d'avoir livré
celle-ci ce que je cherchais quelque
chose de pas loin quelque chose de
montréal est est ce cela peut diminuer
la portion qui est gardée par les jets
un pixar en train mais plus on restera
pour moi c'est parfait
récemment les voisins du québec l'état
de new york et l'ontario ont imposé des
plafonds aux entreprises de livraison
ici rien n'est prévu pour l'instant pour
réguler le secteur
eva comme d'autres initiatives locales
entend se faire une place de choix sur
le marché
pourquoi subir l'innovation d'ailleurs
quand on peut nous mêmes faire cette
innovation loeb vient enrichir notre
propre société ici monsieur prost radio
canada montréal